Question about sonas, what are good sonas, what are bad sonas, what are our choices?
So you guys know I'm very big on sonas and I think sonas are a fantastic way to take
pressure off of your liver and your kidneys because you're using your skin as a portal of
detoxification.
So anything you could do to help take pressure off your liver and your kidneys and your colon,
the better off you're going to be.
Sonas also serve for a cancer patient to possibly raise your core temperature up a little
bit, which can kill cancer cells directly.
So sonas have multiple functions now these two sonas and there's two sonas that we sell
in our store.
Some people love these.
Some people hate them.
These are the ones that you sit in and your head comes out this top of the sauna.
This one here is the one I personally have at home.
We used to only have these sonas, the price of these went up to about $1,500 though.
This is the Thurosage sona, which we just started carrying, which I think is possibly
even a better sauna and it's less expensive.
I think there's some better quality materials in this sauna, though I've had no trouble
with this sauna and I really like it.
This Thurosage sona is, I don't think it heats up quite as fast, but I think it's
probably a little better quality and it is, I think, $300 less expensive, too.
I like the ones that your head sticks out personally because I'm not dealing with cancer,
the neck or above, so I don't need to heat up anything higher than my neck and I don't
feel claustrophobic at all.
This sauna, with my sinus condition, if I sit in a full wooden sauna, that's step together
that you can buy.
I feel like I can't breathe and I just can't stay in there as long.
These ones I can stay in there longer, it heats up much faster, so the wooden ones that
step together, the positives of those is that your entire body is in there and you sweat
a lot from your head, so you'll start sweating from your head and there can be some benefits
from that, too, so there can be benefits from the wooden ones that you get into, that you
turn on.
The negatives of those is that you are getting some gas off-gassing of the wood itself.
Well, it's a cedar one, well, I know, but that cedar off-gassing isn't necessarily good
for you.
So that is a possible negativity of the wooden sauna.
Secondly, it takes a little bit longer to heat up, I think it takes 10 or 15 minutes for
it to heat up for you to go in there.
These ones literally heat up in 30 seconds, you turn it on, you climb in there and you zip
it up and it about 30 seconds might as heat up and you are cooking.
So any sauna, you always start, so the other question is people ask, well, how long should
I do sodas?
How frequent should I do sodas?
You could do sodas daily, once a day and the maximum is 30 minutes.
Now, not very many people, you might, somebody might, this call might be in the category, but
not very many people consider the sauna for 30 minutes every day.
Personally, the maximum I got up to is I think 25 minutes when I was doing, and I do them
in the winter, I don't do them in the summer.
But when I start again this fall, I'll probably be able to get there about 10 to 12 minutes
and I like, I got to get out of here and I'll zip it again up.
So if, and then you work your way up, and I do not do them every day, if you did them a
couple of times a week, that would be good.
Somebody said you can't see my screen.
Do we lose our screen shot here?
I don't think so, it says we're still screen cherry, I don't know, I'm sorry.
So if you do search on our store for sodas, these, the ones that we're talking about are
the only two that you will find.
So these are the ones that zip up, your head is exposed.
The pros of that is you can still, you're not breathing air that you're sweating into.
You are not taking time for it to heat up, you're not getting claustrophobic in the sauna.
And the other side, the other positive is that it doesn't take as much space up.
The wooden staff together ones are more expensive, but there's some benefits having your whole
body in it and you're sweating from your head.
The negatives, it takes a longer to heat up.
So there's pros and cons to all of them.
Some people like to sauna with their, with their spouse or family members, and then you have
to go with the wooden ones, they make four person sodas or larger, back to use, no more
than 30 minutes a day, but typically if you're going to do it daily, you're doing it less
than that.
Typically the temperature is set at 140 and typically you're doing it a few times a week.
If you're doing it every day and you're sweating like a pig, then you may want to make sure
you consider, you may be taking extra scoop of greens or take some minerals, magnesium,
because you will lose some minerals by sweating as well, and you don't want to, and I put
my crisps or something like that.
So make sure you're not demittoralizing yourself too much by doing too much soda, just like
I've said in the summer, when I don't work outside and sweat like a pig, I might take
some extra minerals, certainly some magnesium.